Das klingt echt wie eine nachrichtenmeldung aus fantasien jedes auto kann von heute auf morgen zu einem elektroauto werden ohne irgendeinen umbau einfach
So ja das ist tatsächlich möglich ist
Heißt die lösung also elektro kraftstoffe wie bitte die auflösung jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist wirklich verrückt jedes auto könnte von heute auf morgen mit strom
angetrieben werden und dabei müsste das fahrzeug überhaupt nicht verändert werden kein umbau keine kosten einfach
So die lösung strom wird verwendet
Um den treibstoff herzustellen und das erfolgt dann vollkommen klimaneutral wenn die energie mit der regenerativen
Energiequellen erzeugt wird also wasser sonne wind und das wäre dann auch eine lösung um die stromspitzen
Zb bei der windkraft abzufangen und den strom zu speichern die lösung heißt ich will hier wird zunächst per elektrolyse wasser in
wasserstoff und sauerstoff
aufgeteilt das ist super simpel einfach ein plus und
Minuspol ins wasser halten strom drauf und am minuspol an der kathode wird reiner wasserstoff
erzeugt und an der anode dem pluspol reiner sauerstoff schon die beiden
Sind ein absolut explosives gemisch und reagieren extrem schnell und exklusiven miteinander eigentlich ideal als treibstoff in
Wasserstoff autos wird wasserstoff ja auch verwandt allerdings geht das nicht mit
herkömmlichen verbrennungsmotoren
dafür muss der wasserstoff mit co2
zusammen gebunden werden und schon haben wir kohlenwasserstoff und damit je nach methode benzin kerosin
Gas und so weiter und so fort und co2 ja das haben wir ja mehr als genug
Es kann aus der luft zurück gewonnen werden aus biogasanlagen gewonnen werden oder mit anderen technologien erzeugt werden entscheidend mitentwickelt
Hat dieses verfahren michael sterner er ist professor für energiespeicher und
energiesysteme an der technischen hochschule
Regensburg und wurde für diese power to liquid und power to gas technik mehrfach
ausgezeichnet und es könnte wirklich die zwischenlösung sein bis die reichweite von elektrofahrzeugen mindestens auf eine tagesreise auch auf autobahnen
Gestiegen ist und sie in wenigen minuten geladen werden können
Zwischenlösungen weil diese technik nicht besonders effizient ist der wirkungsgrad liegt bei rund 2 20 bis 30
Und noch ist der kraftstoff ziemlich teuer letzteres würde sich aber nach der markteinführung schnell ändern und man müsste die
Mehrkosten verrechnen die im moment entstehen weil
kohlekraftwerke die netze belegen und
windkraftanlagen deswegen abgeschaltet werden müssen dann wird dieser treibstoff plötzlich sogar richtig preiswert weil ausschließlich über
kapazitäten für die produktion von e views genutzt werden würden bei elektrofahrzeugen liegt übrigens der wirkungsgrad bei
70 prozent und strom sogar billiger als fossile brennstoffe und das auch langfristig allerdings steht die
politik mal wieder auf der bremse
Bremse laut stern will man hier erst das netz ausbauen bevor energie gespeichert wird das wird ungefähr noch zwölf jahre dauern dann sind dann
mal eben 40 milliarden euro verpulvert worden
Da könnte ich ja mal wieder dampf ablassen oh man also wenn ihr kein video zum thema
Elektroautos das ist ja eines meiner lieblingsthemen und auch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich den genau
Auf die glocke nur dann werde sie auch über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter und dafür unbedingt draufklicken bald nur noch
elektroautos technik vor technologiesprung ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran